bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8
politique l'invité de cette édition du
27 mai 2014 constance le grip bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau eurodéputée ump
depuis 2010 sera reconduite pour un
nouveau mandat dimanche dernier vous
allez nous accompagne au cours de la
prochaine demi heure puisque forcément
il sera question de ce scrutin européen
mais pour le moment l'actualité
politique du jour c'est la démission
annoncée de jean françois copé au 15
juin mis en accusation dans le cadre de
la sphère bygmalion du nom de cette
société en communication affaire qui
mêle soupçons de surfacturation
accusations de fausses factures pour
camoufler des dépensiers à la campagne
de nicolas sarkozy la direction du parti
sera assurée par françois fillon jean
pierre raffarin alain juppé des anciens
ministres d'ici au congrès d'octobre
constance ne grille est ce que l'ump
veut survivre à ce marasme bien sûr que
l'ump peut survivre et l'ump doit
survivre l'ump c'est le rassemblement
des familles politiques de la droite et
du centre droit c'est une
famille politique existe depuis très
très longtemps dans notre pays que je
considère comme utile à notre pays à la
démocratie est bien évidemment l'ump va
survivre et l'ump doit survivre et nous
allons tous collectivement nous y
employer même si aujourd'hui il ya une
forte division et même cette direction
collégiale qui fait sourire d'ailleurs
un des alliés du parti chrétien
démocrate c'est jean frédéric poisson
qui est député des yvelines lui a tweeté
aujourd'hui il parle avec ironie de
magnifiques images de renouveau il dit
aussi que ça ne va pas régler la ligne
politique de l'ump quel est votre avis
c'est le défi qui nous est posée alors
que les politiques vous souhaitez eh
bien il va falloir en discuter bien
évidemment nous sommes une grande
formation politique
un peu à l'image
du partido popular español oulad céder
aux riches des raids de notre diversité
addition de sensibilité à ses voisines
mais néanmoins distinguée à certains
égards certains sujets on aura à coeur
de dégager une ligne politique central
pour ma part j'ai des convictions qui
sont à la fois on va peut-être y revenir
très européenne mais qui sont également
à bien des égards je dirais notamment
les domaines économiques et sociaux
libéral social donc j'aurais plutôt
tendance avec d'autres à être sur ce
positionnement là mais nous sommes
conscients du fait qu'il y à des
positionnements différents et qu'il
faudra travailler ce qui nous rassemble
il faut un nom aujourd'hui pour diriger
l'ump à nourrir aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy qui doit
revenir comme certains le soleil on
pense pas qu'il soit dans les projets de
nicolas sarkozy que de s'emparer la
présidence du parti mais il est trop tôt
pour dire quel sera celui ou celle qui
pourront à l'issue du congrès porté les
couleurs de notre famille et vous verrez
une attente j'ai une attente
effectivement on n'est pas de mes
responsabilités et l'esprit collectif oh
oui tout à fait est ce que cette cette
affaire a joué dans le scrutin européen
parce que là on reparle de cette affaire
bygmalion de financement des difficultés
de l'ump mais on en parlait aussi avant
le scrutin est ce que ça a joué est-ce
que ça a démobilisé votre électorat je
pense que ça a joué à la marge mais je
pense que ça a joué effectivement il ya
eu quand même pendant deux ou trois
jours une déferlante médiatique une
surexploitation
j'allais dire politico médiatique fait
d'un sombre allégations et d'un sombre
d'articles et de régulation qu'ils n'ont
pas pu avoir un appel ça ne produisent
plus tôt s'il sera peut-être permis
d'assainir la situation et l'ump avant
de se présenter devant les électeurs
écoutez je n'ai pas pour habitude de
faire de la politique fiction de
reconstruire le film
ou le refaire le match après coup
faisant face maintenant aux difficultés
qui se présentent à nous il ya eu je
crois ce matin lors de la réunion du
bureau politique statutaire un grand
esprit de responsabilité qui a prévalu
et puis allons tous ensemble maintenant
dans l'opération de rénovation et
d'amélioration de la gouvernance dans
notre famille politique ce qui nous
amène en tout cas maintenant à parler
des résultats aux européennes le scrutin
qui a vu la victoire du front national
qui a raflé 24 sièges votre formation
arrive en deuxième avec 20 sièges et
puis les socialistes avec 13 sièges
votre premier sentiment à l'annoncé de
ces résultats dimanche aujourd'hui le
parlement européen et représenter
majoritairement la france est
représentée majoritairement parlement
européen par le front national là vous
l'avez bekhadda majoritairement parce
que 74 eurodéputés sont français
représentent 24 sont pas rationnels 24
qui fait une forte proportion mais c'est
pas une majorité c'est un tiers un gros
tiers des effectifs parlementaire
française on parle des suppressions sont
effectivement occupés par des membres du
front national le premier sentiment
dimanche soir ça a été la déception et
la tristesse déception pour ma famille
politique
pas de mention être cinq ans est d'avoir
su entraîner plus les lectrices et des
lecteurs avec nous et puis tristesse
parce que je ne sais pas si on le mesure
pleinement ici en france mais nous avons
déjà des premiers échos nous de ce que
pensent les autres pays européens de ce
qu'on pense notamment nos collègues
tristesse devant la dégradation
et la perte d'influencé la dégradation
de l'image de notre pays et la perte
d'influencé qui va résulter de ce
scrutin dans les cinq ans à venir
à moi entendu au parlement écouter de
manière générale la position de la
france à l'heure actuelle dans les
institutions européennes n'est pas bonne
le présent la république française a
tout au plus si on en croit certains
sondages 18% de soutien il est celui qui
nous représente au sein du conseil
européen il est extraordinairement
affaibli extraordinairement
démonétisé et la débâcle essuyée par le
parti socialiste dimanche choc dernier n
a fait qu à rajouter à ce discrédit cet
affaiblissement de la france au sein du
conseil européen du conseil des chefs d
iron man maintenant au sein de
l'assemblée parlementaire européenne
donc l'autre institution politique de
l'union européenne le parlement européen
c'est un tiers de députés européens
envoyés par le front national dont a
priori on ne s'attend pas à ce qu'il
soit extrêmement travailleur je dirais
extrait du monde dédié à
infléchir la future législation
européenne faire des amendements prendre
des projets de rapports
dialoguer négocier entrer dans le jeu
politique le jeu parlementaire qui
essaie lui et du du parlement et donc ce
sont autant de députés en moins en
quelque sorte autant de voix autant de
poids en moins pour la représentation de
la france dans cette assemblée est donc
ça va avoir des conséquences
incroyablement négative pour notre pays
c'est sûr aucune formation politique ne
parvient réellement à progresser si ce
n'est le front national et puis
peut-être aussi le centre le modem seul
en 2009 faisait un peu plus de 8% des
suffrages 1 en france avec lui des lits
sous l'étiquette l'alternative ils sont
un peu plus de 10% est ce que c'est un
allié le centre qui vous a manqué dans
ce scrutin incontestablement oui nous
avions fait listes communes
membre de l'ump avec les centristes en
juin 2009 et ça me permet d'ailleurs que
des soignants très largement en tête
nous dans cette configuration la
maison ils nous ont manqué et je
regrette qu'on n'ait pas réussi à être
suffisamment attrayant pour nos amis
centristes qui avaient voulu se comptait
partir dans une stratégie
d'autonomisation et d'indépendance ceci
étant il progresse peut-être
relativement en score et en pourcentage
des suffrages exprimés mais en termes de
parlementaires centristes français
envoyé au parlement européen il régresse
puisqu'ils étaient 12 6 q sicile unisys
modem et ils ne reviennent casse est
donc globalement leurs opérations ne
s'avère pas concluante en sa faveur à
habas essaie de revenir plus tôt dans le
construire avec nous une vraie force
politique de la droite et du centre
droit je pense que les gars en plus aux
dangers que représente la progression du
front national pour notre pays il nous
faut travailler à configurer de l'offre
politique pour les prochaines échéances
électorales dans un esprit de
responsabilité et donc réfléchir à être
beaucoup plus rassemblé entre formations
de la droite et du centre droit on va
écouter justement à propos justement de
ce rapprochement avec l'ump du centre
bruno myle jens est le responsable du
modem dans le département des yvelines
il figurait sur la circonscription ile
de france sur cette liste l'alternative
il réagit aux résultats de sa formation
alors je suis
vraiment très satisfait du score dans
l'unique ville parce que à titre
personnel c'était la première grosse
campagne sur la gabegie m'engager et on
fait le deuxième meilleur score d'île de
france derrière les hôtels
donc ça prouve une chose c'est que si on
fait une campagne sérieuse
pédagogique qu'on va partout expliquer
aux gens ce qu'est l'europe et qu'elle
est notre projet aidé en obtient des
résultats et là je voudrais remercier
aussi les minutes en v des modèles ont
bossé sur le terrain comme des fous il
fallait qu'on montre notre conviction
européenne et qu'on ait des résultats
on les a eus et aujourd'hui il faut
noter une chose on met le quatrième
politique français le troisième
démocratique je dirais mais le quatrième
parti politique français va falloir
compter avec le socle est là nous ne
céderons pas aux sirènes de l'ump qui
ont déjà commencé hier soit c'est un
vote désiré juré de voter fn mais ça
c'est normal entre les affaires d'un
côté la capacité à remonter la france de
l'autre côté eh bien je pense que les
votes fn que des votes désespéré aussi
bien que les abstentionnistes
on vient d'entendre nous ne serons pas
une variable d'ajustement va pas
vraiment l'impression que les centristes
de l'alternative ont envie de retourner
dans le giron dans le cirage dans le
sillage de l'ump non mais il s'agit pas
d cueillir dans notre giron il s'agit
simplement d'être en situation de
construire pour l'avenir pour l'avenir
de la france une coalition une coalition
politique qui
serait une coalition pour la
présidentielle est une coalition pour
les élections régionales qui suivrait
donc d'être dans un dialogue
entre partenaires qui se traduisent par
la détermination d'une plateforme
politique commune de choix stratégiques
communs je rappelle simplement que une
grande partie des députés européens
centriste sortant la mandature qui
s'achève honte siégé pendant cinq années
avec nous l'ump au sein du même groupe
parlementaire au sein du parlement
européen ça veut dire qu'il est quand
même possible et même je pense hautement
souhaitable encore une fois compte tenu
de danger du front national à l'avenir
que de travailler ensemble de renforcer
nos liens il s'agit pas de casser je ne
sais quelle
configuration partisane cas c'est
l'alternative ou cassé je ne sais quoi
mais simplement d'être dense
la construction d'un vrai accord d'une
vraie coalition on va encore parler
d'europe avec vous avec cette question
auquel h quels changements à attendre
maintenant que les eurosceptiques les
europhobes ont progressé mais tout
d'abord vous avez la parole que pensez
vous de la place du front national aux
européennes c'est vous qui vous exprimer
quoi qu'il en soit ça change pas
beaucoup et pas beaucoup de taf que ce
soit fn ou n'importe quel côté politique
c'est la berd je trouve ça dommage c'est
tout je suis atterré surtout par
l'abstention parce que si neuf
électeurs sur dix avaient voté ce qu'est
banques mais vous peut-être qu'il
n'aurait pas voté fn franchement c'est
dangereux pour tout le monde on a
l'impression que ça va être dangereux on
ne sait pas encore enfin c'est un peu
fermé sur le monde ça c'est dramatique
mais faut pas non plus s'étonner qu'on
en soit arrivé là quand on voit les
autres partis politiques comment ils se
comportent les affaires l'absence
d'objectivité l'absence de vision à long
terme donc voilà les français se sont
exprimés c'est regrettable mais j'espère
sa phrase paraît très élevé un sursaut
des autres partis politiques
vous qui êtes élue au parlement depuis
2010 est ce que vous avez le tout de
même le sentiment que les partis
politiques dans leur ensemble se sont
coupés aussi de la base de l'électorat
ils n'ont pas réussi à tisser des liens
suffisants pour que les électeurs en
france même dans les autres pays
européens se sentent concernés par
l'europe alors nous avons un constat le
mans a tiré les leçons de ce scrutin et
je le disais tout à l'heure je regrette
que nous n'ayons pas été plus
convaincant que pas réussi à briser les
rêves de manière plus frontale le mur de
l'indifférence attirer à nous des
électeurs convaincre des
abstentionnistes j'adore mais le vrai
parti politique c'est ce qu'on a entendu
qu'elles que soient partis politiques de
toutes façons ça mais on paye peut-être
aussi maintenant je dirais
collectivement la facture de la
stratégie dite du bouc émissaire un trop
longtemps dans notre pays c'est un sport
qu'elle est absolument je voulais dire
très pratique et c'est ce que je
m'apprêtais à dire tant par les
gouvernants de droite que le gros
langage tant par les parlementaires de
droite gérer que les parlementaires de
gauche c'est la faute à l'europe c'est
la faute à bruxelles sans qu'on sache
très bien qu'ils étaient bruxelles avec
une méconnaissance totale de ce qu'est
bruxelles recèle c'est nous ou slc les
chefs d'états les chefs de gouvernement
les ministres des 28 états membres donc
nos ministres et puis ce sont nos
parlementaires nos parlementaires
nationaux comme nos parlementaires
européens nous bruxelles c'est nous donc
c'est la faute à bruxelles c'est la
faute à l'europe était un gi milk facile
une facilité politiques et
intellectuelles dans laquelle nous
sommes certainement trop longtemps qu'on
plus et dont nous perdons payons
maintenant le prix avec une perte en
crédibilité en efficacité en vérité et
en transparence sur ce qu'est la réalité
du pouvoir politique il est partagé le
pouvoir politique la france comme
l'allemagne comme la slovénie comme
l'italie comme l'espagne ne décide plus
tout seul dans son coin mais
décide de prendre ensemble de chemin de
prendre un certain d'orientation
politique d'un commun accord avec ses
partenaires européens mais ça c'est une
réalité je dirais moderne du pouvoir
politique tel qu'il fonctionne
aujourd'hui que nous n'avons pas eu
suffisamment explique vous aller siéger
une fois de plus un pour cette nouvelle
mandature dont le groupe majoritaire le
groupe du ppe avec les différentes
forces de droite même si la majorité
sera moins forte de son 13 sièges 190
pour les forêts de 213 214 jours les
sièges des socialistes et ses 190 donc
l'écart s'est un petit peu resserré au
delà de 16 qu'aujourd'hui le front
national va être en mesure d'imposer ses
choix non est-ce que les eurosceptiques
les europhobes vont réussir à faire
sortir leur pays de l'europe revenir à
la offrant non d'abord toutes tendances
confondues je dirais depuis les
eurosceptiques jusqu aux plus
extrémistes jusqu'aux europhobe c'est à
peu près entre 24 à 25% des effectifs du
nouveau parlement européen
encore une fois tout globalisé et donc
ça n'est en rien une minorité de blocage
ce n'est en rien une force qui va
pouvoir stopper je dirais tout détruire
détricoter déconstruire et le prochain
parlement européen va celui qui se met
en place au 1er juillet prochain n'est
pas incompétent en matière de sortie de
l'euro n'est pas compétent en matière de
sortie de schengen ça n'est pas
l'apanage de parlement européen que de
décider sur ce genre
au sujet de grandes orientations
politiques qui sont à discuter et à
décider entre chefs d'état et de
gouvernement entre responsables
politiques
est ce que je dis arrêtez de l'heure en
tout cas vont changer peut-être compris
stablement de manière générale après un
grand moment de vérité après une
élection européenne les formations
politiques quelle que soit ta coeur non
seulement de décoder décrypter analyser
le message le message les messages
envoyés par les électeurs mais aussi à
coeur d'y répondre est d'avoir au cours
de des années à venir des réponses
appropriées nous avons entendu un
message nous en tout cas ici en france
me semble-t-il un message pour une
europe plus forte pour une europe plus
protectrice pour une europe qui arrêtent
peut-être de réguler réglementer un peu
trop à foison dans toute une série de
domaines sur toute une série de sujets
où on estime que c'est plus énervant
agaçant et contreproductif qu'autre
chose mais une europe qui se concentrent
qui se resserre centre de compétences
ensemble sujet sensible de grandes
politiques et donc nous allons nous
notamment nous les parlementaires
européens ump travailler à cela qu'on
sent très resserrée l'europe semble de
grandes politiques ou neuf occasions ont
été quelques-unes et faire en sorte
d'arrêter peut-être l'hyper
réglementation l'hyper inflation
législative dont on a bien compris que
nous compatriotes avec ac on va revoir à
présent les résultats en ile-de-france
et les résultats yvelines également
ile-de-france avec l'ump qui est arrivé
en tête près de 22% blé à des suffrages
exprimés suivi du front national 17,3 du
parti socialiste 14,3 et suivent l'ailé
centriste de l'alternative europe
écologie et le front de gauche qui
envoie donc des députés au parlement
européen puis dans l'est yveline
également le front national qui a
progressé mais qui est encore loin de
l'ump puisque l'ump presque à 25% alors
que le front national est à 18% même pas
qu'ils en sort plutôt bien comment vous
expliquer qu'en ile-de-france et dans
les yvelines le front national et et du
mal à progresser autant que dans le
reste de la france écouter de manière
générale la lecture que nous faisons
nous des résultats du front national est
celle de la colère du ressentiment de la
déception très forte et de je dirais la
désespérance sociale je pense que c'est
cela les principaux déterminants du vote
du front national alors je ne veux pas
dire que en ile-de-france et parlement
dans les yvelines il ya moins de
souffrances sociales - de ressentiment
moins de colère mais peut-être ya t-il
quand même si on compare à d'autres
grandes régions je pense au nord ou à
l'est des situations économiques des
situations sociales un regard sur
l'avenir on regarde sur son propre
avenir différent et qu'il y a moins le
sentiment d'être totalement je dirais
cernée par un torrent de de force dont
on ne sait pas très bien voilà comment
ils s'organisent ray ou d'être menacée
dans son identité peut-être qu'il y a un
mal être un malaise existentiel qui
existent ensemble de grandes régions
françaises je pense notamment aux
régions frontalières pour les tas de
raisons et qui existent mois en
ile-de-france autour de la
région-capitale je dirais il y a quand
même une certaine c'est ce que montre je
pense le score et de l'ump et d'autres
formations politiques d'airé
progressiste leur matière européenne une
certaine confiance en l'avenir une
certaine confiance en soi une volonté de
continuer à avancer le front national
aujourd'hui en france appelle à la
dissolution vous partagez cet avis il
faut dissoudre l'assemblée nationale il
faut revoir redistribuer les cas je suis
pas du tout favorable aux incantations
aux déclamations et aux appels à la
dissolution je suis respectueuse des
institutions de la vème république
apporter stabilité et solidité à
notre république et donc je me garderai
bien de camper dans des postures aussi
des cannes à thouars et ce ne serait pas
forcément favorable à l'ump non plus
parce que l'indépendant - ça
simplifierait pas forcément on regarde
la situation avec indépendamment des
calculs politiciens des prévisions voilà
et des jeux de billard à triple ou
quadruple le monde je pense que la
légitimité du suffrage universel direct
elle est dans les mains du présent
république et que brandir voilà des
appels à la dissolution ça n'est pas
être conforme à l'esprit des
institutions ces institutions que le
général de gaulle a donné à la france et
auxquels je suis moi personnellement
très attachée on va écouter à présent
jean michel c'est le maire d'elancourt
ils étaient présents sur votre liste de
l'ump en septième position il n'a donc
pas été élu mais il a fait campagne à
vos côtés pour cette liste ump non il
nous parle de l'avenir de l'ump sa
vision des choses parlent également doré
guaino puisque henri guaino partage pas
tout avis tout à fait votre position
député des yvelines vous parlais tout à
l'heure de ce rapprochement avec les
centristes nécessaires pour construire
henri guaino lui n'a pas envie de
devenir un parti de centre droit c'est
ce qu'il a exprimé récemment voix s'il
n'a pas été tendre je reprécise aussi
pendant la campagne avec alain
lamassoure la tête de liste m et voici
les déclarations à présent de
jean-michel fox monsieur guaino a
d'énormes qualités intellectuelles
d'écriture minéraux qu'une culture
économique s'il avait un minimum de
culture économique il qui voyait les
entreprises que c'est la première le
premier partenaire commercial quand même
des entreprises françaises l'europe que
c'est un tiers de nos emplois mais qu'il
n'aurait pas dit toutes ces bêtises mais
cela dit j'ai mis en dehors de ça bon
voilà donc restons à son soft quant à
l'ump bon l'ump je vous dis à chaque
élection on attaque le président du
parti bon l'ump on l'a vu en les
municipales on vient avec la même
histoire d'ailleurs quelques jours les 8
0 ben moi je ne sais pas je connais pas
ses dossiers il faut qu'on mette une
équipe qui fait gagner c'est la réguler
à la tête d'une entreprise on est une
équipe qui fait gagner à la tête d'un
parti aussi bon si monsieur
si monsieur copé est celui qui fait
gagner m'a écouté il faut le faut le
suivre et de maintenir si c'en est un
autre ben là c'est la règle du jeu je
n'ai pas de préférence particulière se
dit j'ai une petite idée quand même de
vous à moi ne me le demandez pas mais
j'ai une petite idée tout de même deux
qui va revenir il évoquait bien
évidemment nicolas sarkozy jean michel
faure houssin lors de cette déclaration
vous ai posé la question tout à l'heure
vous n'avez pas vraiment répondu je vais
vouloir poser qui pour incarner l'ump
aujourd'hui qui souhaiteriez vous sur
telle ligne souhaitez vous vous
positionnez alors la ligne politique on
va là déterminer ensemble encore une
fois
une femme va bien sûr des folies
brutalement la sphère politique mais je
pense que la priorité des priorités
c'est de mettre un peu de sérénité et
d'apaisement et de calmer les tensions
et de sortir des jeux de personnes et
des chocs des ego qui de manière
générale font trop de mal à la vie
politique et font en ce moment trop de
mal à l'ump donc de la sérénité de
l'apaisement une gouvernance collégiale
qui se donne pour tâche de préparer le
congrès et qui nous laissera le temps
aux uns et aux autres de travailler à
forger une ligne politique majoritaire
génie ce qu'était ma sensibilité à moins
que je partage avec d'autres une
sensibilité je dirais libéral
humanistes sociales et européennes mais
je rebondis jusqu'à ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure moi non plus à l'instar
d'henri guaino je n'ai pas envie que
l'ump devienne un nouveau parti
centriste j'ai pas de transformer l'ump
pour que l'ump
perdu une partie de ses troupes une
partie de ses spécificités se
rétrécissent et devienne un nouveau
parti centriste un parti de centre droit
il s'agit simplement de créer les
conditions d'un travail commun et d'un
rapprochement qui permettent de
travailler à élaborer une plate forme
commune des projets politiques comme
l'homme où la femme pour travailler à
tout cela donne ou non le temps
2 je dirais digéré le score d'évoluer au
ps affirme serait surmonté la crise on
la gouvernance parce que je vous ai pas
posé la question mais la gauche qui
rencontrent des grandes difficultés ce
qu'ils nous préparent et alain est ce
qu'il faudrait pas que la gauche aussi
se réaffirmer est ce que pour le jeu
politique démocratique se serait pas
positif aussi pour l'ump d'avoir un vrai
adversaire à gauche et non pas un
adversaire à la droite de la droite
alors je n'ai pas de conseil à donner à
nos adversaires socialistes constatent
simplement qu'effectivement au soir du
25 mai le total de toutes les voix de
gauche à peine 1 33% des suffrages
exprimés n'a jamais été aussi bas dans
notre pays que c'est une débâcle un
désastre politique et électoral pour
françois hollande et manuel valls et
aucun effet valls est manifestement
françois hollande de leurs nerfs absents
pas réussi son pari maintenant de
manière générale effectivement je
préfère que les formations commencent à
voir de manière à avoir un dialogue puis
je dirais sparring partner digne de ce
nom qui appartiennent plutôt à la
catégorie des partis de gouvernement est
effectivement mais ça fait des années et
des années qu'on dit que le parti
socialiste français
au rebours de tous ses grands alliés
européens à commencer par le spd
allemand n'a pas fait son bad godesberg
n'a pas fait la mue politique et
idéologique qu'il devrait faire et c'est
en partie certainement la raison de son
échec actuel les responsables politiques
de gauche nous allons les écouter à
présent dans le département et ce sera
pour conclure donc cette édition du 7 8
politique on est un parti très pro
européens mais qui n'a pas suffi à mon
avis dire à ces cas l'europe on voulait
et à quel point l'europe qui a
actuellement en place n'est pas celle
que l'on veut donc il ya une confusion
entre le fonctionnement de l'europe
actuellement et le est ce que portent
les les partis pro européens il ya des
messages qui ont été qui ont été données
la dimanche gens qui se déplacent pas
ils disent quelque chose ce qui vient de
voter fn on peut considérer qu'il ya un
socle de gens qui sont qui adhère
vraiment aux idées du front national
mais je pense que majoritairement ce le
message c'est pas ça c'est un message
contre l'europe telle qu'elle fonctionne
actuellement et contre le système
politique en général en france contre
les partis politiques donc ça il faut le
prendre en compte l'analyse et puis
ensuite apporter les réponses et
d'apporter les réponses c'est forcément
se remettre en cause il faut en
permanence aller voir les gens sur le
terrain voir nos concitoyens discuter
avec eux moi je crois vraiment que pour
réenchanter la politique il faut aller
discuter je pense que le manque de
dialogue aussi peut expliquer un certain
nombre de votes parce qu'il ya des
incompréhensions donc quand on n'est pas
content on envoie un message qui est un
message aussi de contestation qui peut
être désamorcée si ce dialogue existe si
les échanges avec les élus existe le
score du front national
à l'issue de ce scrutin la s'explique
par une forte abstention
qui est l'abstention de l'électorat de
gauche qui effectivement est déçu par
une série de politiques d'austérité que
le président de la république
nous assène depuis deux ans monsieur a
un très bel avenir
nous allons continuer à élargir l'espace
de rassemblement à gauche et puis aussi
à progresser dans la construction d'un
véritable
opposition de gauche l'alternative c'est
le front de gauche c'est que le front
national propose n'est pas une
alternative crédible
la crédibilité et de l'autre côté la
politique d'avenir qui consiste à
ressouder la cohésion sociale qui est en
train de s'effriter du fait des
conséquences des politiques d'austérité
je pense que ça c'est nous en fait le
front et le front de gauche incarne
aujourd'hui l'avenir de ce pays là
l'invité de ce set 8 politique c'était
constance levry merci d'être venus en
plateau députés ump réélu donc aide
dimanche prochaine édition et d'ici une
quinzaine de jours et toutes les
précédentes éditions sont à revoir sur
notre site internet à bientôt